Цю тактику данські військові застосували ще два роки тому.
Потенційних солдат кібервійськ вони стали шукати
на великих виставках комп'ютерних ігор.
Тому не випадково представники міністерства оборони Данії
опинилися на виставці для геймерів у Копенгагені.
Цим же шляхом, до речі, пішов і німецький Бундесвер,
який уже шукав новобранців серед відвідувачів виставки Gamescom у Кельні.
Зазвичай у них розвинені комунікативні навички
і здатність повністю концентруватися на вирішенні завдань.
Вони легко навчаються. Загалом вони кмітливі,
швидко ухвалюють рішення і здатні до роботи в команді.
Серед завдань кіберсолдатів - боротьба з терористами в інтернеті,
захист урядових мереж Данії від кібератак.
Військові цінують досвідгеймерів.
Ми і так сидимо по десять годин на день перед комп'ютером.
І якщо ми можемо бути корисними для армії, це було б непогано.
Кібератаки вже давно стали для НАТО реальною загрозою.
Їх проводять і підконтрольні окремим державам структури.
Зокрема, ЗМІ торік називали у цьому зв'язку РФ, Китай та КНДР.
Данія бере активну участь у гарантуванні кібербезпеки НАТО.
Кібервійска тепер стають окремою одиницею в НАТО.
У нас є війна на суші, на морі і в повітрі,
а тепер війна може вестися і в кіберпросторі.
Власні кібервійська Північноатлантичного альянсу,
до якого входить і Данія, обіцяють сформувати до 2023 року.
Наприклад, у боротьбі з угрупованням "Ісламська держава"
добре використовувати наступальну тактику, тому що
ви можете припинити їхню діяльність в соціальних мережах у вербуванні найманців,
отриманні винагороди їхніми бойовиками.
В армії обіцяють подбати і про боєздатність солдатів кібервійськ.
Перед тим, як допустити їх до комп'ютерів військового відомства,
їм належить протягом декількох місяців пройти
спецпідготовку - це стосується і фізичної форми.
Але важливими залишаються і навички геймерів.
Можливо, це просто комп'ютерна гра, однак для геймера важливо виграти.
Але, звісно, потрапити в кібервійська може далеко не кожен геймер.
Військові зазначають, що солдати повинні бути не тільки досвідченими гравцями,
але й володіти іншими важливими якостями.
Цих якостей на виставці комп'ютерних ігор
Gamescom у Кельні шукав і німецький Бундесвер.
А саме - геймерів, які б могли поповнити його лави.
Для цього німецькі військові навіть організували на виставці власний стенд.
Тут були присутні справжні солдати і навіть військовий транспорт.
Однак не всім припали до смаку рекламні плакати Бундесверу.
Геймери у соцмережах скаржилися, що на плакатах,
де збройний конфлікт прирівнюється до комп'ютерної гри,
применшені негативні наслідки воєн.
Війна - це не гра, кажуть любителі віртуальних стрілялок.
Тож, армії ФРН доведеться продумати іншу рекламну кампанію,
аби набрати до своїх лав нових рекрутів.